this continent knows
the true meaning of racism
its peoples
have both been perpetrators of racism
against others
and themselves
the victims
of an insane
and murderous
racist ideology
[Music]
we understood
that we could not end the nightmare
by surrendering ourselves to the passion
of hatred
and the spirit of vengeance
and retribution
we are striving to proceed
in a manner
and towards a result
which will ensure
that all our people
both black and white
emerge as victims
we recognized
president dick
and his colleagues
in the national party
as men and women of integrity
we are therefore prepared
to work with them
to arrive at a just
and lasting
negotiated solutions
[Applause]
it must result in the transformation of
south africa
into a united
democratic
and non-racial country
anything less than this
would condemn our country
to worsening
and economic conflict
every adult south africa
must have the right
to pass it to participate
in governing our country
through a system of one person
one vote
the human rights of all our citizens
must be guaranteed
the apartheid system in our country
continues
we continue to be ruled
by a white minority government
all the other pillars of the apartheid
system
have not yet been removed
the masses of our people
must therefore continue the struggle
within our own country
the international community
shares the same obligation
we thank you most sincerely
for awarding us
with the soccer of christ
we take it
as a challenge above all
to have the courage
to fight
for justice and
peace whatever the obstacles
we shall try
not to fail you
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you